I don't know everything happens for a
reason and just when you feel like life
is falling apart really it's coming
together
Daisy Keach wants to make two things
clear she's a founding member of the
hype house and she loves and cares for
every single one of her former
housemates as of late March 20 20 days
II is no longer living in the content
mansion and she couldn't be more
thrilled
living in hype house was a nightmare
from lawsuits and fake friends to mind
games and red flags
Daisy spoke out about her Heights house
experience and it's even worse than we
thought keep watching to find out why
Daisy feels like Thomas Petro is an
opportunist who lies cheats and
manipulates to get what he wants I think
everyone on the internet kind of knows
them I'm like the dad of the house he'd
love to be able to tell people what to
do when to do and how to do it
Dan's had high hopes for a hype house
when it was first announced in late 2019
but no one had higher hopes than Daisy
cute we put in some hard earned cash to
get the creator collective going
flash-forward to late March 2020 and
Daisy's hopes and dreams are up in a
puff of smoke and she has Thomas petrol
and chase Hudson to think for that Daisy
hired an armed security guard to escort
her through the hype House mansion as
she collected her belongings and while
this might sound extreme she did it to
protect her rights and business which
she told Forbes had been completely
stripped away from her
the famous tick-tock er is officially
all moved out but her feud with Thomas
and Chase is far from over
Daisy filed two separate lawsuits
against her former friends and Heights
house co-founders
however chase and Thomas's talent agency
has refused to comment on the whole
ordeal let's take things back to the
very beginning to fully understand what
went wrong between Daisy Thomas and
chase on March 28 2020 Daisy uploaded a
YouTube video titled the truth about the
hype house in which she talked about how
she met and befriended Thomas in a
little background of the Atanas we were
good friends before we even started this
whole thing together Daisy revealed that
she and Thomas were really good friends
before choosing to start a business
venture together
Daisy met Thomas at team 10 mansion
where he asked her if she wanted to
collaborate on a photoshoot but shortly
after Jake Paul kicked Thomas out of
team ten and the Brooke content creator
had nowhere to go
Daisy offered Thomas a job as her
photographer and editor helping him get
back on his feet what she didn't know
however was that Thomas was just using
her to get ahead look more on that later
Daisy says that she and Thomas were best
friends right off the bat they saw each
other everyday and confided in one
another around this time Thomas met
chase and talk of creating a tick-tock
mansion began to circulate Thomas Daisy
Alex Warren and Coover anon joined
forces and met with chase at his Airbnb
in LA they came up with the idea to form
the hype house together and within a few
weeks they visited a mansion that would
soon become the hype house and here's
where things start to get messy to rent
the mansion the tick stalkers had to cop
up a 46 thousand dollar deposit
but Thomas Alex and Krueger were a
little strapped for cash so they only
put down about $5,000 each
Daisy and chase on the other hand were
able to put in eighteen thousand dollars
each securing the LA mansion as soon as
the collaborators moved in Thomas
created social media accounts for the
hype house choosing to keep the
passwords to himself which was a big red
flag for Daisy but since he was in
charge of posting content she didn't
think much of it at the time things took
a turn for the worse when New York Times
came to the hype house to conduct an
interview chase and Thomas had their
managers with them during the interview
but Daisy did not which made her feel
intimidated according to Daisy Thomas
and chase took total charge of the
interview taking all the credit and
leaving Daisy Alexei Coover out of the
equation they were power tripping hard
and it didn't go unnoticed looking back
Daisy wishes she would have spoken up
and set the record straight
but either way she's proud of taking her
stance
defending ourselves even though she
admits she acted a little too late keep
watching until the end to find out which
celebrity Daisy was spotted grocery
shopping with in LA here's a hint he's
16 years older than her and has familial
ties to the Kardashian clan after the
New York Times interviewed Daisy talked
to Thomas about how she was feeling she
said she felt like he should have given
her and the other co-founders more
recognition and he agreed with her
that's what made his next actions all
the more puzzling Thomas would go on to
appear in a handful of other interviews
and continue to pretend like he was the
hype house mastermind I feel like I just
have a good ear and eye for this stuff
this was a major red flag for Daisy
whose hideouts experience was taking on
a nightmarish tone with each passing day
when she found out that Thomas was
taking all the credit again
Daisy realized she was being manipulated
things got even worse when Daisy's
lawyer called her informing her that the
media was saying that Chase was the one
who paid to get the hype house going
her lawyer pointed out that she was
receiving zero recognition despite being
a co-founder so Daisy confronted Thomas
once again and that's when he began
showing his true colors instead of
telling the truth about the hype house
Thomas stopped giving other members
access to the group's email accounts
Daisy and the others had no idea how the
collective's money was being spent we
were focused on more of the family bond
more of the collaborative effort thomas
had everyone collaborating on brand
deals but was tight-lipped about whether
or not the gigs were paid thomas
repeatedly told his housemates that hype
house wasn't making any money
and yet the formerly broke team 10-star
bragged about expensive purchases like
an $8,000 bracelet and a $10,000 cat
Thomas allegedly even talked about
buying a brand new Tesla
this caused hype House members to get a
little suspicious
what's worse is that Thomas refused to
give anyone the account passwords
we can't ever have any group decisions
like everything is him like he somehow
has authority over everything so what
was he hiding
Daisy also revealed that Thomas wouldn't
give any of the team members access to
the hide house Instagram account
Daisy soon realized that Thomas enjoy
telling people what to do she even went
as far as to say that living in
house was like living under a Thomas
touch of dictatorship if things weren't
bad enough already
Thomas approached Daisy asking her to
manipulate a potential hype House member
this and one more thing would lead to
Daisy ending her friendship with Thomas
for good according to Daisy Thomas
wanted her to act like she was this
mystery girl's best friend to lock her
down as a tik-tok collaborator I never
thought in a million years he would do
something like this to me Daisy couldn't
believe what Thomas was suggesting
that's when she realized that he was
constantly manipulating people for
personal gain following this incident a
co-founder approached Thomas with a
press deal but Thomas forbade him from
taking part in it according to Daisy
Thomas justified things by saying it's
not your decision because I make all the
decisions around here Thomas started
making legal decisions behind Daisy's
back too that's when Daisy fired back
confronting Thomas about his actions and
the way he treated people he apologized
to her face and said he would be more
inclusive and transparent but chose to
cut her out behind the scenes Daisy's
lawyer / manager called her up soon
after to inform her about what Thomas
was seeing behind her back according to
her lawyer Thomas had said that he was
much more of a business man and that
girls like Daisy were just hot Instagram
models with a shelf life
ouch now that's gotta hurt finding out
that Thomas who was supposed to be her
best friend had said this about her
really stung so she confronted him only
to hear him repeat the same lies Daisy
realized that she had to legally protect
herself from Thomas so she filed for the
hypeeeee house trademark and Thomas
blips when he found out so I filed for
it I let Thomas know he tried to tell me
that I filed for it incorrectly Thomas
continued to try and cut Daisy out of
legal affairs refusing to put anything
into writing it was around this time
that Thomas began ignoring Daisy and her
lawyers calls but things really hit the
fan when Daisy walked into the heighth
house to find out that Thomas was
shooting a huge music video without her
consent which is illegal because he
hadn't received
permission from the landlord this led to
a huge fight between Daisy and Thomas
Thomas said that she had given everyone
noticed in the group chat
however Daisy rebutted by saying that he
never gave them a date what's worse is
that Thomas used Daisy's bedroom as a
dressing room without asking her first
Daisy walked in to find her bedroom
occupied by dozens of people which is a
total invasion of privacy
during the confrontation Thomas tried to
convince Daisy that she had no say in
the hype house telling her that she
invested money simply to live in the
house and not to be part of the business
side of things taking things a step
further Thomas immediately used the hype
house social media accounts to block and
unfollow Daisy Daisy you're getting
hosed right now you need to speak up for
yourself
but he didn't stop there according to
Daisy Thomas also hosted a team meeting
in which he encouraged group members to
unfollow and block Daisy as soon as
possible
Thomas was power tripping and using his
influence to make others think that
Daisy was problematic however most of
the members had experienced Thomas's
manipulative ways firsthand so they
remained in contact with Daisy on March
9 2020 it was revealed that the hype
house Instagram page had unfollowed
members like Patrick Houston Connor
Yates Calvin gulby and Wyatt Xavier so
it's believed that these members chose
to stick by Daisy's side but things
weren't as simple for Alex and Kivar who
have remained silent over the feud the
same goes for Charlie D'Amelio all drama
aside Daisy is choosing to take the high
road and let the port's handle the rest
when it comes down to deep down in my
heart I forgive I forgive however legal
battles could take the backseat now that
social distancing laws have come into
effect
Daisy informed fans in her tell-all
YouTube video that this would be the
last time she talked about the issue she
just wanted to clear the air and tell
her side of the story
Daisy is choosing to take her hype house
experience as a life lesson which she
says she'll grow from but if there's one
thing the tick talker is truly done with
it speak la
Daisy is ready for the next chapter in
her life I'm gonna show you the next
chapter in my life and I'm really really
excited to share this with you if
there's one thing Daisy wants fans to
take from all of this it's to always
trust their intuition she also stresses
the importance of getting things into
writing before putting money down Daisy
wants to surround herself with positive
people especially now that March 2020 is
coming to a close and social distancing
rules are in full swing on a lighter
note
Daisy cute was spotted shopping with
Brody Jenner on Friday March 27th at a
supermarket in Los Angeles according to
E news the pair were seen flirting
before Daisy got into Brody's car what
do you think about Daisy's take on
Thomas and chase sound off in the
comments and be sure to tell us what you
think about Daisy and Brody's newfound
relationship thanks for watching give
this video a big thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe for more we'll see
you next time on the theme
you